How's the online personality tests coming along?
It's coming along pretty well.
We have all the reports written and we have the,
um,
the underlying computer architecture finished.
And at the moment we're just polishing it up essentially.
And we're hoping that you'll be able to get a very detailed description of all
five of the big five traits,
right?
Extroversion.
That's a positive emotion dimension.
Um,
that's,
that will break down into enthusiasm and assertiveness and neuroticism.
Now it breaks down into withdrawal.
Like if you're in a state of withdrawal,
then you're frozen with fear and,
and don't want to do anything.
You're afraid to go out.
You're,
you're afraid to engage in any complex task because you might fail.
You'll dealt yourself intensely.
That's withdrawal in neuroticism.
And then volatility is that kind of impulsive touchiness that people often
develop when they're in a bad mood.
You know,
where if you reach your finger off to touch them,
they'll flinch and maybe slap you.
And they're over sensitive to small slights and they don't have much of a sense
of humor.
Um,
and agreeableness that subdivides into compassion and politeness and the liberal
types are more compassionate and the,
uh,
conservative types are more polite and politeness seems to be something like
acting in accordance with the social norms governing interpersonal interaction.
Whereas compassion seems to be the proclivity to side with the weakest party,
something like that.
And I think it's the primary maternal dimension because the perhaps alone with
higher levels of negative emotion because,
um,
it's obviously the case that when you're dealing with children,
especially infants,
that you should take the side of the weaker party pretty much no matter what the
logical argument and sprite because an infant who's crying is always right,
especially if it's under a year old.
There's no logic to it.
It's,
it's an a priori fact that a crying infant is correct.
And so we don't know how that translates into the political sphere because the
most direct translation would be,
um,
a complaining person is always right.
And you know,
I see that manifesting itself.
I would say great.
Clearly in the politically correct domain is that you always side with the
person who's manifesting negative emotion.
And you always assume that there is an external reason that needs to be
rectified in order to,
um,
to deal with that.
And you know,
it isn't obvious to me that agreeableness as an ethic is something that is
transformable into the political or the adult landscape.
But,
um,
well,
you know,
we don't know these sorts of things and we can't even talk about them because
people automatically assume that that's sexist or misogynistic or even though
you know,
there are agreeable manner as well as a group of women because men are quite um,
maternal for,
for,
for the kind of large apes and mammals that we are.
But we need to take these sorts of things seriously because it isn't obvious to
me that an ethic of agreeableness can govern a complex polity.
It looks to me more like conscientiousness is something that needs to govern
arm's length transactions and that sort of thing rather than treating everyone
like Ken that you just can't do so you don't have the energy.
Um,
anyways,
the test will also associate conscientious or assess conscientiousness.
That's orderliness,
which is seems to be associated with disgust,
sensitivity and is a good predictor of conservative belief and industriousness,
which is something like the,
well it's what it says exactly.
It's the proclivity to engage in effortful work towards a defined goal in a
reliable manner and it's the second best predictor of longterm life success
after Iq.
And then the final thing it'll upset,
assessed is openness to experience,
which is more or less half creativity.
It half interest in ideas.
And so if,
if you take the test,
you'll get a boat,
it's about a 10 page report and it gets quite detailed and it tells you where
you fit on a percentile basis and what your strengths and weaknesses are going
to be.
As a consequence,
we're going to produce a couple's version so that two of you can take it and
then you'll get a report that tells you how you're similar and different and
where you're likely to have disagreements and agreements where it's going to be
difficult to negotiate a consensus.
That'd be where your Wyatt widely different from one another on a trait.
Like it's hard for an extrovert and an introvert to come to an agreement about
how much socializing they're going to do because the extrovert says,
well,
let's socialize all the time in the introvert says,
you know,
once a year would be plenty for me.
And those aren't opinions right there.
They're built in preferences that are far beneath the realm of opinion.
And if you're high in openness and your partner as low in openness,
like you're going to be interested in the theater and arts and literature and
philosophy and,
and talking about ideas and,
and going to museums and not sort of thing and your partner,
it's in some sense it will be like they are colorblind,
they just won't find that sort of thing engaging and interesting at all.
And you might be able to shift someone a little bit to a higher degree of
openness,
but it's,
it's not an easy thing to do.
And so we think in the literature seems to indicate that you should be fairly
well matched on most of your traits with your partner,
uh,
with the possible exception of neuroticism,
because it isn't obvious that two people who are highly neurotic can get along.
Uh,
neuroticism is a pretty good predictor of marital unhappiness,
just like it's a good predictor of every other form of unhappiness.
So.